[Musique]
bien sûr on assiste à une résurgence de
l'antisémitisme est à nouveau et
malheureusement la question de
l'antisémitisme se pose en france elle
se pose avec la multiplication de crime
antisémite et je voudrais simplement
citer les victimes de mohamed merah à
toulouse je voudrais aussi citer les
noms de sarah limites llan halimi mais
aussi de me éric noël mais pour prendre
l'exacte mesure de ce phénomène il y as
je le rappelle cette étude de l'institut
ifop qui montrait que 7 français
d'origine juifs sur 10 ont déjà dans
leur vie subi un acte d' agression
antisémite ces chiffres sont absolument
affolants
veux pas évoquer les outils les
solutions les remèdes contre cet
antisémitisme sans en voir les causes
jadis l'antisémitisme c'était une pensée
qui était structurée notamment par une
forme d'extrême droite avant la guerre
la deuxième guerre mondiale aujourd'hui
malheureusement cet antisémitisme il se
déploie dans les quartiers perdus de la
république est gagné par l'islamisme
radical donc je pense que les solutions
c'est la fermeté on ne doit rien céder
et notamment face à un islamisme radical
il faut constamment réaffirmé nos
principes nos valeurs et lutte et de la
façon la plus déterminée contre toutes
les manifestations qui vise à conquérir
dans le territoire français mais aussi
dans l'esprit de nos compatriotes un
certain nombre de positions qui sont
radicalement contraire à l'esprit
républicain
bien sûr que cette résolution elle est
faite pour protéger nos compatriotes de
confession juive mais pas seulement
cette résolution elle vise aussi à
protéger la france parce que les actes
antisémites évidemment qu'il s'exerce
contre une catégorie de français mais ce
sont d'abord des actes d'agression
contre la france contre notre histoire
contre notre projet national et contre
l'essence même de ce que nous sommes